Saturday Night Live is off to its
hottest star in eight years in a lot of
it has to do with these two right here
but what's gonna happen when they throw
Tom Hanks in to me that could be magical
he's hosting a week from tomorrow so
Carly steel asked him about SNL when she
caught up with him in Italy I was
backstage with Gaga one her golden globe
for American Horror Story so feel like
we're part of her sphere of influence so
Italy so we're yes we're Monster gaga
what would you like to do in this
upcoming well you gotta wait to see
what's happening well I hope to be able
to work in an imitation of Ron Howard's
ha ok I'll be waiting for that did he
did it give you a preview ok ok the
modern story that's good it's good ok ok
I don't really do that I don't think but
uh who knows really good feeling good
anyhow kaylee good everything ok oh no
now fully how he's got Felicity doing
that well here's Tom's thing you'll come
in and said hmm ok let me get this
straight you want me to start at the top
of the stairs and tumble all the way
down while I'm talking this is what
you're this is what's in the script and
is what you're talking about I think you
need to take that SNL stage by storm and
come in your highness impression and
battle and I'm not sure that that's that
that's the hell of an idea it's
whispered to Lorne Michaels they know
each other so well their new dan brown
thriller infernal marks the fifth time
ron has directed Tom on screen Dante's
Inferno isn't fiction it's a prophecy
someone created a plague Tom travels the
Florence to contain a super virus from
wiping out the human race offset he took
a little time off to romance his wife
Rita Wilson we went out on a night time
of the old motor cruise on the Danube
that way
that was funny hey don't get lucky after
that you're doing something you gotta
level Tom recently surprised a couple in
Central Park on their wedding day
officially not by on me the secret of a
good photo bomb is timing and locale and
as I was coming up to this wedding party
was unfolding before my very eyes
congratulations
you